Thank
you.
Thank you.
Buddy!
Hey guys!
Hello everybody!
Welcome to Cookie Run Kingdoms!
A huge shout out to Cookie Run for sponsoring today's
stream.
You guys can see in the description below.
I do have links that you can click to use to install Cookie
Run to help support the stream and the game.
So please feel free to click on the link in the description
or that's pinned in the comments It really does help a lot
because it helps you know encourages My sponsors in the
future and everything so yeah Daniel cookie run kingdom
today even though you haven't seen me play it yet You know
just because you haven't seen me play it Doesn't doesn't
mean that's gonna stop you from downloading it right now So
you can play along with me, you know play along with me guys
But yes, again, a very huge shout-out again to Cookie Run
for reaching out to me.
Especially because I've never, I've never, yes, supporting
your streamers blindly is the way to go.
Good things always happen when you support somebody blindly
with no evidence.
But you know I'm going to make this game look great.
I'm also trying very hard not to swear because like this
game is very...
This game is way too cute to swear right now
So I have my inner filters on
Okay, let me bring down the music just a little bit And then
we're good to go Alright, so I've actually I've actually
Never played Cookie Run before I've always seen a lot about
this game have like a lot of different games too this like
uh it has like a different types of games as well it's not
just kingdoms um but uh this is actually my very very first
time playing cookie run i always loved the designs of cookie
run like i've seen like especially cookie run kingdom um
i've i've always loved the designs because i mean this guy
is so freaking cute i hesitate because i had But apparently,
this cookie is called Cream Barret Cookie.
And they look really, really cute.
And I honestly think all the designs are actually really
adorable and everything.
And I know the Cookie Run fandom is also very big and very
fanatical, too, regarding...
Because it was so funny.
I was looking at...
Also, I turned down this music already.
So let me know if it's better.
But it was so funny because...
Cookie Run retweeted my tweet, and then I was looking at the
tweet replies, and then people were just like, we're like,
oh my god, does this mean, does this mean you're going to
add dragons into Cookie Run?
So I thought I was so cute.
They like have their own fandom and everything, and like
have like fan art and stuff like that.
It's like, it's really cute.
I thought it was like really, really cute.
I'll turn down the music a little bit more again.
Um, let me know it's a lot better.
Um, but yes, apparently there is, uh, there is a new update
in, in this game called My Cookie, and that is what we're
going to be checking out.
I will be using an account that Cookie Run has given me,
and, uh, you know what that means?
Free gotcha pulls.
I love free stuff.
I I haven't I had let's go gambling I haven't done gotcha in
a long long time so that should mean that should mean I have
stockpiled my gotcha luck into it to pull some sick ass is
ass a swear okay I don't know it's a body part so it
shouldn't be sick ass cookies even though like i have no
idea if my cookies are rare or not but like i'm that's the
best part if it's a bad pull i'll still be happy
so oh well you're right a lot of body parts are i can say it
right up for it i swear but there is a there is a lot of
stuff been this new update that i i was told so there is
apparently there's a town square now and then there's like
the my cookie uh design feature where you can basically
customize your own cookie sona so your own so it's like a
first sona but what if you're a cookie uh so you could be
like that gingerbread man in shrek i think i don't know wait
i oh my god i mean it's it's literally a man so it's got me
right you can be your own cookie soda so uh you can make
your own cookie soda and in the my cookie so it's they're
called icings that can be earned from like various things
like sugarcoat cookie salon the weaving shop or certain
events or even like shop packages i can buy so many
cosmetics oh my god i haven't checked yet how much money i
have in the account they gave me so i'm gonna spend it all I
need to make my cookie soda.
And yes, and also the new special cookie, as you see here.
Look at this giant ass ferret cookie.
Apparently that is a half furry half cookie because they are
the cream ferret cookie.
Oh my god, the amount of times I've said.
Every amount of times I've said cookie.
Biscuit.
All right, for all you EU people, there a cookie is like a
biscuit so you can make your own biscuit sonas i'm very
diverse i'm very inclusive um uh but yes i'm very excited
there's also like a limited gacha banner called summer vacay
costumes as well as some limit time events so let's go check
this out uh there was an intro i have no i have not entered
the game because like when i entered there was an intro so
like there So I was scared of, like, I was scared that if I
click on, if I went in fully, I would miss the cutscene.
And I don't know if it's important.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's important to the cookie lore.
So let's get right into it.
But yes, huge shout again to Cookie Run for sponsoring this
stream.
I really, really do appreciate it, guys.
All right, let's go in.
Hello.
Connecting.
Also, I brought music down already, sound guide.
Let me know if it's better now.
Hey.
I heard a lot of people spend a lot of money on this game.
Is that true?
Any Cookie Run enthusiast willing to tell me how much they
spent?
And even if you're not proud of it?
Uh...
Yes.
Oh, my God!
There's narration?
That's great.
I don't have to read.
Holy shit, $1,000?
Holy shoot.
The filter did not work for me when I saw that amount.
Sorry.
I saw that amount and my filter stopped working.
Wait, is that the king?
Is this the king of Cookie Run?
Custard Cookie the third.
Are all the king's custards?
Who let this child be the king?
No, that's a kid.
Time is money.
Chili pepper cookie, where are you going?
Where is she going?
She's really speedy when there's treasure involved.
Wait, if he's not the king, then who gave him the crown?
A blueberry, you're not a cookie!
Who let this bird in here?
This is a cookie run!
Kingdom.
Who let this bird in here?
Bundle?
That's my treasure you're talking about.
What is that?
That's ice cream.
This is a baby?
That's a baby?
What is that?
Oh my god.
Oh, it's a cookie dough.
That means you you bake the baby.
You put the baby in the oven as a cookie That's so cute.
That's actually really smart.
Oh my god, you put the baby.
Oh my
Someone put that baby in the oven
What if I microwave the baby like custard cookie the third
and friends of the cookie cana us we met this cute little
buddy while on our adventure so cute unfortunately where
we're headed is not safe for a doy little oh my god they
abandoned their baby that's messed up this they disowned the
baby they put it in the orphanage i'm confident that this
little one will grow up big and strong in the cookie kingdom
under your care Oh my god, it's like in those shows where
they leave the baby at the doorstep and be like take care of
it That's his baby?
Who did ginger brave put the baby?
Who did ginger brave put the baby in the oven for?
It's a baby
Wait, so is he a pretend king because he says into my
kingdom?
kingdom.
Who's the baker?
Yeah.
Will this baby become?
Oh, he's like a pretend king.
I see.
Aww.
Let bros think he's a king.
Goo goo gaga.
This is why you got disowned he's
like it's your problem now
someone freaking I'm sorry the baby got me someone throw
this baby into the oven so we can speed the process
I can talk?
You're an animal!
Wait, who are you?
Is that your fairy?
The baby's a fairy!
Pass the baby.
Oh god.
Please.
I need to skip the baby.
Look
at my fluffy Are they gonna put the ferret in the cookie
dough in the oven together?
Oh my god, they're gonna get fur on the cookie dough Who's
gonna eat you now?
Wait, it grew?
How it's still there?
Poof?
What?
Everything I was talking about cookie run in the last 10
minutes gone.
Is it like a werewolf?
I'm a cream ferret.
That doesn't answer me.
Are you a cookie?
The cream critters?
Oh, it is a persona!
Okay, oh, oh, he defused.
I thought they fused.
I legitimately thought they fused.
I was like, wait, what happened?
You're happy to see me too, huh?
I can't explain how or why, but I feel like you were calling
for me.
My powers were sleeping for the longest time, but thanks to
you, they've awakened now.
Oh, hey, okay, I get it.
This person can turn into an animal.
I get it.
Just because they're, like, a free babysitter.
Do not leave the baby.
Wait, did we skip already?
Did we skip a couple?
Where's the baby?
It says taller.
Clearly not tall enough.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah,
because we can't even see the baby
Toothingless baby dough Wait The cookies have teeth
The cookie running a kingdom door is so deep I didn't even
realize they have teeth It's gonna be okay I'll give you a
big hug for being such a big cookie where's the baby where
did the baby go Oh tooth sing oh it's like a tooth link with
the icing it's icing tea oh
I get it does that mean there's a tooth fairy there's a
tooth sing to sing oh my There's a Tooth Sing Fairy?
Wait, the Blueberry Bird is a Tooth Sing Fairy?
Your new Tooth Sing is going to grow back all nice and
pretty.
Just like mine.
See?
Huh?
Did you just call me a king?
Aren't you my best?
Oh no.
No, don't follow the false king.
He's a fairy.
No!
The thing spoke.
Monster.
Burn the cookie.
It's only been a day.
There's something wrong with that baby.
Where's the freaking...
Oh, that's me!
Don't burn the cookie!
It's me!
Oh my god, don't burn the cookie!
No, I was the baby on the log!
No, I got disowned.
I'm an orphan.
Turn off the oven.
Turn it off.
What a plot.
Everything I said about the baby, I was just joking.
Hee hee ha ha.
I don't really need a cook.
Do I get to dress up my cookie?
Whoa!
Welcome, my cookie update.
The town square is...
is back.
Complete in the quiz game.
Cream Ferret Cookie is here.
New season of Arab Busters in the Kaku Town Square.
New Darkness Artifact and Cookie Alliance.
Dressed for this.
Oh, this one.
This is a new gacha that they have.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can be a Ferret too!
Okay.
And then there's like this.
Oh, the Cookie Run Tower.
Oh yeah, this is the newest event.
Alright.
Wait, can I...
How much do I have?
Oh, I have...
Wait, I can!
What happens if I wake her up?
Oh.
I'll wake her up.
I have enough money.
Are you awake?
Wake up.
Wake up!
Keep trying.
I won't stop.
Wake up!
What do you mean?
I thought you were my babysitter!
Are you serious?
You're supposed to be my babysitter!
What's shake-up?
Oh, I shouldn't shake up.
I don't think I have enough.
That's not fair!
You're supposed to babysit me!
Oh, just because I grew up, you're gonna stop babysitting
me?
Just because I'm not a baby anymore.
That's so messed up.
But can I attempt on the Snapdragon cookie?
No, I can't!
I did it dirty.
This is not fair!
Also, I need to...
Fix the volume, so give me a sec.
Let me... Just because I'm not a baby anymore.
Don't...
They think they can just leave?
Okay, I turned down the music again.
Also turned down the effects, too.
I'm so messed up.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it would do such a thing.
How many crystals do I have?
Yes, by the way, like I said, Huge shout out to I didn't
know I huge shout out to the cookie run for giving me an
account because I never played cookie run before Oh my god,
there's so many things to do my name is yeast powder
Oh my god, there's so many things oh yeah, there's the town
square wait are those all the other cookies Oh, this is my
cookie?
Oh, these are my cookies.
Oh my god, this is my town oh my god this is my town oh my
god that's a lot yeah that wait not tap you sorry daisy
there's a daisy there's a daisy cookie wait is there oh oh
is this like oh i got special goods oh my god i'm rich oh my
i don't even have pick up money.
How many cookies do I have?
Oh, there's Default Dan!
There's Gingerbread Man!
There's Default Dan!
Oh my god, there's babies!
We'll put these gnomes in my...
Oh, wait, no, they're just decoration.
Sorry, that's just decoration.
Oh my god, I'm gonna spend all the money.
Sorry, this is not even what I'm supposed to show you guys.
Sorry, I got...
I got really curious.
about the decorations and everything.
Wait, oh my god, there's...
Wait, you're not a cookie?
You're just goofy!
You're literally...
You're literally just...
What are you doing here?
You're not even a cookie.
You're not even cookie shaped.
You're not...
Who let these Disney characters into my cookie game?
Gosh.
Gosh, Gosh, Sora, it seems the keyblade took us to Cookie
Run.
You're not...
You're not edible!
Alright, we gotta go to Town Square, because that is like,
apparently the newest features that they did.
If I could see it.
Whoa.
Wait, you look rather frazzled.
Well, I've been busy with the Town Square.
It's okay.
Just a little...
We're just here for the audio.
It's loading.
You're just too funny, chili pepper cookie.
Who's this?
This here is an invitation I made.
Oh, really?
Where is it?
That's right.
We now have a festival to celebrate the reopening of the
town square.
Oh, the festival!
Please do come as we're making preparations.
I'm starting to smile, friend.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay, there we go.
Oh, a Gojo sim.
How can I get a Choco Chalk without...
Hey, guys.
I'm new here.
How do I move?
Oh, here it is.
Hey, I'm Yus Powder.
Hey, everybody.
Hey, luck is on my side today.
Hey, guys.
Oh, my God.
That's my cookie.
Hey, everybody.
What do they use to type in RuneScape?
We'll chop wood for gold.
Oh god, wait, I think, I think I, oh my god, why is there a
lizard in my cookie kingdom?
Why is there a lizard there?
There's a guy called I hate cookies.
Wait, buying cookies for 10.
Buying cookies for 10 cookies.
Buying 10 cookie baby.
Oh, shit.
No, that's not it.
Sorry, that's my live chat.
Buying cookies for cookie babies.
Cookie babies for 10.
For 10 cookie.
Hello, everybody.
Oh my god, the paparazzi!
Guys, the paparazzi is here!
Oh no!
No photos!
The jig is up.
I'm not...
Doki, I'm yeast powder.
What are you guys talking about?
I'm yeast powder.
Oh, there's like villager assistant cheese bird.
Oh, I want to... Wait, I want to... I want to redecorate my
cookie.
Do I leave here?
Leaving Town Square.
Sorry, guys.
I need to... I need to redecorate my cookie.
Oh, I should turn up the...
Okay, let me... Settings.
Okay, let me turn down the music a little bit more.
And then... Turn up the volume.
Alright, let me know if that's better.
Okay.
Oops, that's not what I want to do.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my cookie!
There we go.
Do I have everything?
How do I?
Eyes really.
Oh, closet.
Closet.
Oh, my God.
I have so many.
Do I?
Oh, I have...
Wait.
I don't have enough.
Equipped.
Oh, I have a hat.
I'm so cool.
And then...
Yeah, I like the face.
I think the face is perfect.
Oh my, there's so many.
Wait, there's lips.
You can change your lip tone as many times as you want.
Just move the slider.
Oh, so I can, like, match the lip tone.
Oh, okay.
I want to keep this.
I think this was perfect.
And then we're going to...
There you go.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's see.
I want to be...
Wait.
I want to...
What kind of cookie?
do i don't want to be i don't want to be a ginger bro well i
want to be a normal biscuit do i have voices oh oh my god um
i have like custom voices
what the like
what Okay,
I actually like the default.
Oh, save.
What is this?
You have no icing equipped.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I don't have any other eyes?
Angie.
Oh, and then...
Wait, what is this?
Okay, these are my eyes.
Oh my god, wait.
Alright, that's cute.
That's cute, though.
Can I...
Oh, that's cute.
What hair do I have, though?
I'm trying to figure out what hair I have.
Is this the hair I have?
I need a specific icing.
Oh, this item is available for a limited time only.
Oh, I see.
But I can't change the...
Can I change the color?
I can't change the color?
Oh.
Wait, what's this?
Honest work bandage.
Oh, no, that...
No, I don't need that.
All right, what are my shoes?
Oh, I think this one looks really nice.
The shoe.
Why am I a waiter?
I don't want to be a waiter.
I was like, why?
Why the world am I a waiter?
Wait, how?
Which outfit is this?
Oh, is this outfit?
I'm not going to be a waiter.
I'm going to...
I'm not going to be...
Not going to be a goddamn waiter.
I'm a cool kid.
I'm going to be so cool.
preppy with the money i'm gonna be preppy all right let's
see yeah my dad can buy your house my dad is your dad's boss
okay let me change the hat to match it to um okay we gotta
remove the hat remove there we go wait unless a blueberry
cap yeah unless I get more yeah I'm the private school
cookie so punchable my dad works in cookie run that's me why
is it polite cookie that is definitely not what I was going
for oh okay wait wait wait wait I could change the name okay
okay Um, 16 bites.
Okay.
Ivy League...
I'm trying to...
Um...
I want to know, like, what kind of cooking...
Put light in parentheses.
Trust...
No!
You know you're they're right they're right They're they're
right though
Okay Okay
All right I'm a nipple baby cookie
okay here this is this is my cookie i would do private
school cookie if i had enough characters p-r-i-v-a-t-e-s-c
oh i had the money i have so much private school cookie all
right guys do i get nepo baby cookie or at school a cookie.
Which one?
Spend them like gems well spent.
Okay, never.
Alright, we gotta get more cosmetics though.
We gotta get... What is this?
Is this a gotcha?
Oh, these are for the outfits, right?
Oh, it's the limited time.
Okay.
Draw five.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I have... Guys!
Do I have...
Oh my god, guys.
I wonder if I have enough, guys.
Okay.
Let's go.
Open up.
Oh?
Oh my god, we're putting the baby in the oven!
Draw.
Oh.
What is that?
Aspenetra Baby Cookie.
Pick.
Oh, I got the mint.
Oh, my God.
Cocktail.
You can't afford it.
Is that legendary?
Did I got the legendary?
Oh, I got another pink.
I hope this sounds a lot better now.
All right, draw.
Draw my cookie.
What do I get?
I got a ribbon.
I got shorts.
I don't need sunglasses.
Mysterious Milky Way hair dye.
Oh, I can, like, change the hair color.
Do I have everything?
No, I'm missing, like, three, three, four, five.
It's okay.
I can keep going.
All right.
Am I going to get it?
Oh, no.
Oh!
Wait, wait.
Wait, I like that.
I like that hairstyle.
All right.
I'm still missing.
It's okay, we could keep going.
Ripped Bottoms.
My dad would not like that.
Ripped Bottoms does not go with a dress code.
I should be gotching for the characters.
I think I'm making regular cookie run plays really sad
because I'm doing gotcha on my cookie instead of, like, you
know, instead of doing gotcha on my cookie.
Instead of on the characters rip bottoms rip bottoms it does
not follow the dress code in my private school Oh, it's a
separate currency.
Okay, uh, that's good.
Oh, that's great.
Okay.
A little a little cookie run All right, let's see
that another rare draw the cookie what did i get oh
sound of the sea oh it's for like when i'm holding it oh i i
got no oh i got this okay i'm just gonna say oh my god oh my
god my dad's gonna love it when i wear these two outfits i
don't know i think i got like what's red Oh, so like, you
can just straight up buy stuff.
Oh, check out our catalog.
All right, I want to see what I can get in the regular.
What does the magic conch say?
Oh, I got another rare.
Let's see.
What did I get?
That's when you know I'm smart.
I got a...
Is there a stain on my white tent top?
I stayed in state.
Wait, wait, tank top.
Okay, closet time.
All right, let's see.
Wait, you can read?
Okay, now I'm going to definitely put on the book.
No, no.
This does match it more, though.
Yes, I can read.
I go to private school.
Wait, how's it still locked?
I thought I unlocked you.
Did I not unlock this?
Oh, do I need, like, a particular icing?
Oh, I need, like, an icing for it.
I see.
Wait, do I have it?
Okay.
What was it before?
Was this?
Okay.
Oh, it's a particular icing.
protection lock so I don't accidentally delete.
Oh!
I see.
Yeah, you know what?
That's very smart, because I would definitely do that.
I would definitely do that.
That's very smart.
Wait, do I get a bow?
Oh, it's like a tail thing.
What's this?
Oh, no, I don't like that.
I want, like, I want, like, a nice preppy shoe I need like
some preppy shoes.
No, those are sneakers.
Dad won't like that.
Oh, everything is mine to equip.
Oh, okay.
Um.
I want to make sure, like...
What's the difference between...
Oh, this is yellow stitch.
Wait, what is the difference between these two pants?
They look quite similar.
What about shirts?
Do I have any new shirts?
No, okay.
Oh, the white tank top.
What is this?
Am I wearing a freaking paper toilet paper?
Oh, there's doubles.
Oh, you can get doubles?
Oh, I'm lucky then.
I'm very lucky.
Alright.
What's the gotcha?
Oh.
What currency do I have?
I think I need more.
I think, oh, not to be very careful.
Alright, so apparently...
Oh, wait!
What is the difference between Vakey Cookie Gotcha and
Gotcha Fate?
What's the difference between Cookies and Limited?
one is limited limited versus standard thanks guys one one
is limited
but they're so oh these are costumes you can dress up your
cookies I get it I don't know if I have those cookies
here hey cookie run huh it'll be funny if like you know i
hide my screen for a little bit and suddenly i have like a
hundred thousand cookie cutters that would be so silly
though wouldn't it cookie run so silly anyway guys i might
need to hide my screen in five
Wait, did I get two autumn leaves?
Wait, I didn't get any of the new costumes.
This is not summer vacation.
It's not.
He's wearing a tuxedo.
I was on summer vacation.
Alright, let's see.
What did I get?
Did I get any rairs?
They have a gnome wizard cookie?
Wait, they...
Okay, that's funny.
They have the gnome wizard cookie.
Please!
Please don't give me...
I haven't done gacha in so long!
Why am I not getting summer vacation?
Why not?
I got gnomed.
I can't believe it.
Alright.
Oh!
I got you!
Oh
my god.
Oh!
She's so cute!
Conductors Summer and get...
Wow, Desert's so cool.
She's so cute.
We already have her!
Okay.
It's a thought that counts, guys.
It's a thought.
I didn't know I already have her.
Who's this?
Oh.
Blasted heat wave away.
I really love her hair.
Her hair color.
It's so pretty.
I love like it's so aesthetically pleasing to look at.
Oh my god.
What the heck is...
What the...
Okay.
this guy, too.
This guy goes to the gym.
This guy is definitely getting some gains.
Someone put some bacon in that cookie.
Do I have all of them, technically?
I wonder, like, how can I tell if I have all of them?
I really, I actually really like these two the most, so I'm
glad I got them.
Like, I'm sorry.
Oh my god, this guy definitely goes to private school.
okay this this guy definitely goes right probability i have
oh i'm literally only missing him i'm missing private school
kid one percent ken brulee what am i missing okay i am
missing i'm actually missing Okay, I guess we have to.
I wonder if I can take his clothes and, like, put it on my
cookie.
Oh, it's so cute!
I love the hoodie.
Wait, is this another gnome?
This is, like, I don't want to go to a school gnome.
I want to steal his fit.
Give me private school.
I want private school guy.
Oh, and Ken Boulay!
Oh, I got another gnome.
Come on!
Oh!
Who are you?
What the heck are you?
You're not my summer vacation.
You're your pomegranate cookie.
Who puts pomegranate in your cookie?
Freak!
Guys, I'm sorry.
I know there's, like, game content.
I need I need Ken brulee Ken Ken is that you
Okay wait Okay you're cute okay I know you're cute but I
gotta complete the set I gotta complete the set Oh my god
two elasties oh she's cute Royal Knight's cute.
Oh, she's cute, too!
Please.
Where's Ken?
Where are you?
How much money do I have left?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Now I get all whites.
How much?
Oh, that's fine.
I don't have to worry.
I can do this for as long as I want.
I can do this for as long.
Oh, yes, I would.
Please, I just need one more.
Oh.
What?
What are you?
Is that even a cookie anymore?
Is that?
Is that even a cookie?
Is that even?
That's like, oh, you know what I found out.
I found out Centaurs have, like, two chests.
Because they have a chest right here.
And then they have a chest right here, too.
So, like, it's weird.
It, like, messed me up a little bit.
Come on.
Summer?
Yeah, two rip cages.
Yeah, that's what I mean.
Sorry, I'm not a biologist.
Kitten?
Yeah!
Yeah, I did it!
It only took like a thousand dollars if I actually...
That's okay.
It only took like maybe five hundred dollars.
It was a pose.
But that's okay.
Now I have the cookie that perfectly represents me.
Alright, so...
Guys, let me like hide my...
No, I'm joking.
I won't hide my screen.
Wait, what's the difference between...
Wait, do I have all of them?
found ancient dark cacao's cookie at soul prism 0.15 percent
we aren't that oh yeah you're right sorry it only took ten
dollars guys ten dollars i don't know how many pulls i did i
i don't know how i've lost count i i lost i lost count how
many pulls i did oh did i found all the no i didn't Stuff I
haven't found there.
There's Epic.
There's Ancient.
It's like 30 cents worth of pulls.
I did.
Guys, that was like 30 cents, by the way.
How do I know like what I...
Oh, I can find...
Oh, Creme Brule Cookie.
I have that.
I have milk.
Oh, it shows here.
Oh!
I have the cookies.
Oh, I have all the God cookies.
I just can't read.
I never can.
Alright, I want to get...
I have all... Oh, I have all of them!
They're the... They're the... The Summer VK!
I'm gonna get the disguise.
Oh.
I don't have a lot of that.
That means I'm gonna spend it.
I don't have a lot, so I'm gonna spend...
Oh!
Oh, I'm pressing.
Is that a magical...
Oh.
I got good pull.
Yeah, it's sparkled.
What are you?
Oh, it's the gnome guy.
With a lollipop.
Oh, is this the rare?
It's the magical one.
It's a rainbow.
Who are you?
Oh.
I got gnomed.
I got god.
Mystic flower cookie.
Wait, is that good?
Is that... I thought I just automatically get a good... I
don't know.
I'm just... I... Every time I do gotcha, I get a... I
thought the user is just normal.
I thought that was just normal, guys.
I...
I don't know, guys.
After you watch this stream and do gotcha, you'll get my
luck.
I told you!
I stockpiled!
Oh my gosh, I got the we combined the gnome and the wizard
cookie together.
We'll get the gnome wizard.
Oh, is she?
Nice.
I'm just that good.
Ooh, the knight cookies.
Oh, beast!
Nice.
I did it.
She's so cute.
She's so pretty.
Alright.
Sorry, I got really absorbed in the in the gotcha.
Anyway, it's time for more gotcha
It's Anyway, it's time Sorry, I got very absorbed with the
gotcha.
Anyway, guys Wait, I want to I want to get out of here.
Okay I need my cookie needs more clothes Guys, I know guys,
I know Like there's other stuff I have to do But I need to
make sure my cookie is like dressed appropriately.
I need...
Guys, I need...
Oh my god, wait, the...
I go...
Wait, I love it.
Why is there...
Why is...
Why can you make your cookie a ball tank?
This is important, guys.
Oh, I got curly hair.
That's prep material!
Okay, we gotta use the...
Okay, let's see.
Busy.
Oh, we haven't done this enough.
Nope.
Come on.
You really are.
This is nuts.
I'm sorry.
My dad, like, bought me so many cookies.
I don't know which one's the special one anymore.
Because they're all, like, normal to me.
Like...
Oh, my God.
wait that okay what golden dukkia on the sticky don't hurt
me like this is that the how am i getting none of the new
icings is that oh no that's not oh there it is that has to
be why am i okay i have one of them i have one of them okay
i just want to collect more i just want to make sure i have
more of it.
I need more clothes.
How else am I gonna, like, make my cookie look amazing.
Oh, that's really cute.
I like that.
Alright.
Let's see.
I have, like, five of these hats.
I think the...
Was the black cap?
I think the black cap suits it a lot better.
I need, like, black shades.
I just need black shades, and then it'll be perfect.
Alright, let me make see like In my In my little I have like
fucking Three freaking six shirts Sorry, I saw too many
shirts I'm sorry
I just had too many red shirts I'm sorry I just had so many
There is too many shirts I couldn't help Oh yes
You guys didn't hear anything, guys.
I feel like...
I don't know.
Is this...
Yes.
I feel like this is definitely...
How do I change the color?
Is it the weave, right?
It's the...
Oh, save.
How do I change the color of my hair?
they allow those my dad is on the sport of directors so of
course they're gonna allow me is it is it gotcha just click
oh it's gotcha too oh so like i have to get the uh where's
all these colors oh mystery oh you want to change it oh They
are random guaranteed and seasonal hair dyes.
I see.
Okay, that's not...
That's so cute.
Okay, I want...
I feel like black hair would make more sense, though.
Right?
I'm trying to figure out.
Guys, I'm sorry.
This is, like, very important to me.
like yes okay you know what yes perfect okay we're good all
right i think i think my cookie okay i think i think my
cookie is ready to go to school make sure i have everything
i want you know what maybe i should change the pants color
black no blue is better blue is better yeah all right nice
all right it's time to go to the town square i want i want
to show everybody my drip a gift has arrived hey guys my dad
owns cookie run
Nah.
Whoa.
That's right.
My dad owns Cookie Run.
Nice.
Oh, and I can complete missions.
and farm currency.
Oh, I can complete missions.
I want to talk to this guy.
Hello there.
Oh, okay.
Wow!
Oh my god!
It's France!
No!
Oh my god, I'm getting here.
I'm getting France.
I mean, I mean...
People of Revolution.
Run, dokey, dokey, dokey.
Oh my god, there's gifts!
I want my reward, my free gift.
I definitely need it.
Which is the best one?
I have 6,000 of that.
How much do I have of this?
I can't tell.
I have 27,000.
Oh, I have less of this.
I'll take that.
Even the rich.
Um, yeast powder.
That's me.
I'm a fashion icon.
Oh my god, everybody is like dressed to impress right now.
They're on.
Oh wait, where's your...
Oh, I can do emojis.
That's right.
Where are the missions?
Where I can jump?
Oh, I can slide.
Wee!
Wait.
Okay, wait.
I'm sorry.
Wee-wee.
Sorry, it's the little things.
It's the little things that get me.
I'm gonna slide.
Where's he?
Where's some of the missions?
Yeah.
Oh, quest.
Okay, daily quest.
That company any?
No, I... Oh, I have!
Yay!
I did it!
I did my job.
Yeah, I did some emotes.
Can I dance?
Oh my god!
Guys!
Please!
No paparazzi's!
I want to dance!
Guys!
No paparazzi!
Let me dance!
Okay.
Eat the eat.
Oh my god.
I can dance too.
No pictures.
No pictures everybody.
I gotta dance.
I can't believe they wouldn't let me dance!
Alright.
Alright, it's cute though.
I like how everybody's fit.
Everybody's has such cute clothes.
Oh, you can hide the chat here.
Everybody's clothes.
They're so cute.
Oh my god, look at... Oh my god, it's the wizard!
It's the gnome wizard!
You can move it.
Oh, jelly worm?
Where's the jelly worm?
Jelly worm?
Are you the... You're the Jelly lizard!
Are you a worm?
So many times I always pondered over...
Oh, silly me.
Oh no, that's not the jelly worm.
That's the jelly lizard.
Where are the jelly worms?
Oh no, she can't read.
Guys, I need to find the jelly worm.
Oh, it's on the right side!
Thank you, I don't have eyes.
I can't see it with all the money in front of me.
Are you the jellyworm?
Is that...
I can't...
Are you...
You're the granola cookie.
Oh, Smighty Jellyworm!
It's because everybody was there!
I found...
I found them.
Oh my god, you're so tiny!
Fulfill 10 wishes?
Okay.
I'm gonna do...
that we'll fill 10 wishes from the tree okay and then this
is claim mail reward oh i can do that where's the mailbox
mail reward oh my god where's my mail oh there it is down
here i see it who left my mail on the floor smithers i
wonder what's inside the vault 5.
Is that my mail?
It has to be my mail, right?
Oh, there's a key here.
Guys, what's the code?
You only get 3.
Guys, who did it?
Guys, we know the third number is 3, guys.
We know the third number is 4.
5.
Guys, we gotta work together.
Oh, nice!
Okay, not.
Thanks, guys.
God, we did it.
Together.
We did it!
Together!
Nice!
Teamwork.
I did it.
Guys.
Yippee I did it Oh is it this?
Alright claim I did my quest I did I claimed it Quest
complete Oh nice All me Oh, there's no request.
And now claim mail reward.
Oh, it's in the town square.
Where the heck is the mailbox?
Where is it?
I want to claim all?
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Make your choice.
I want Ungabunga string.
I want...
I always want to be strong.
Alright, I did it.
I did it, Mr. Silkworm.
Or smart jelly...
Sorry, smart jellyworm.
Talk to me.
It's so hard to see.
Did I not...
Did I get it?
Did I not get it?
Guys.
Where's my mailbox?
I'm not used to...
Guys, I'm not used to having a mailbox, guys.
Why mailbox when you can email me?
Oh, top right quest book.
Claim one reward.
Press the quest.
Oh!
Oh, wait, no.
No.
Never mind.
Wait, guys, we're learning.
Oh, they're the red puppies.
Wait, I talked to them already.
They're mailboxes?
We use dogs for mail?
I'm learning so much.
Oh my god, they are!
Look at these freaks.
Look at these little silly guys.
No, I'm ready!
I need to wait an hour!
We can't be shoved, Mel.
No!
Look at these non-cookie freaks!
You're not a cookie!
We use you for a Mel because you're not a cookie.
A genaglia engineered to join the poster.
Did we make them like that?
Oh, we're the monster all alive.
The cake houses are built a different, okay.
Alright.
I think we explored a lot from the kingdom.
Oh, I claim leaving town.
Yes, give me everything.
Yes!
I want it all!
I'm never satisfied.
Give it all to me.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
There's apparently...
Oh my god.
Who are you?
You look like the...
The anime boy that's about to...
You know, in like anime.
They're like, you know.
They're like, I'm here to help you.
because I need all the help I can get.
Oh my god, what are you?
That's not a cookie.
Wait, is that a BTS cookie?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he is.
Wait, who are you?
Oh my god, it's him.
It's, oh my god.
It is him.
Wait, what's your story?
but oh my god it isn't no way wait what's your story what's
your story meet everyone's darling demon cookie oh my god
wait what about mickey or goofy what's his lauren cookie run
where is he where's goofy i need a fight cookie no not you i
don't care about you i care about Goofy.
There's so many cookies in my kingdom.
What's some butt these dogs?
Guys, there's too many cookies in my kingdom.
I'm trying to find.
I'm trying to find Goofy.
Where are you Goofy?
What?
This is gonna be awesome.
What's your lord?
Tails is a very special fox.
You're not even a cookie.
Where's the cookie part?
Oh, my goodness.
Tails, that's not a cookie.
Of course.
Now the two are the best friends and the one.
Tails knows his way around.
Oh.
But when Sonic help he has gain in it.
Let's promote you.
I have.
Do I not.
Oh, not enough soul stones.
How many...
Upgrade.
Your skill can't exceed.
Don't worry, I got you.
Let's go.
There we go, we did it.
Now you're the...
Now you're the strongest...
strongest cookie out there.
Tails is meta.
You will be...
You're not one star.
You will be meta.
I'll make you the strongest cookie out there.
Alright, nice.
Now we have a strong tails.
Now clean my kingdom.
The strongest one star.
Wait, can I actually?
Okay.
Oh, it's the quiz game that's the newest thing that's the
newest event so i'm heading over to it's not a game time yet
come back later in 43 no it's so close
i can't believe it i was just too late i was too busy guys i
was too busy lovely upstairs leveling up dance what's this
it's also a new event this one what's this combat preset or
apparently you use it to combat a preset order of any waves
to battle earn points to receive rewards as well as try oh i
want to battle battle please oh it randomized oh there it's
over it's over for them it's so over I wish it brought
tails, though.
Time to fight.
It's okay.
What did I do?
It's over.
Get them out of here.
Oh my god, you're just...
Oh wait, no, no, no.
They're okay.
I did it.
Yay!
Yeah!
Damage, receive, minus.
I did it.
Select a cookie to swap?
198.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Where's my tails?
I want my tails to come in.
Okay.
Click everything.
No!
Why not replace?
More damage equals more.
More damage equals strong.
All right, cooldown decreased equally to increase food.
Oh, attack speed!
Wait, no, this one.
Wait, it's blue.
Wait, that was yellow.
That is yellow better than blue?
Of course, I'm yellow.
Wait, auto?
Oh.
123 more.
Oh, that's HP.
More attack.
More attack equals better cookie.
I will replace every cookie.
Oh, that's a god.
cookies oh guys why didn't you stop me guys why didn't you
stop me you could have stopped me you know i don't read
attack 56 000 yes
boss it's just a cake use everything go my cookies go is
this speed oh wait that's a lot better see look it's so easy
when an alley summon oh yellow yellow is better 59,000 is it
tears.
198, 26,000.
183.
29,000.
This guy.
Now my characters have summons.
Eventually it'll happen.
It'll happen eventually.
Oh my cookie's dead!
No!
Why did I choose This is cookie!
Guys, why didn't you stop me?
What?
Guys, you could have stopped me.
Why are they so strong?
Is it custom metal?
No!
My other tank is gonna die!
But it has so many attacks!
But bigger number!
Are you trying to tell me bigger number doesn't mean
anything?
Oh no, guys, I don't think we're gonna...
Guys, guys, he's not doing so well.
Guys, are you trying to tell me?
Numbers?
Strength?
Strength doesn't mean anything?
Is that...
Oh no, king, please!
They're so low, King!
Please!
Why don't you do anything at level 80?
It's over.
Not without something.
Who got the 59,000?
Is that my high score?
Healy doesn't He's Oh all he does is heal Oh that makes more
sense now You know that makes a lot of sense That all he
does is Heal I'm still trying to find goofy Oh gosh Oh
Donald
Give the white fluffy cookie A blueberry jelly bean Oh my
god He has a little cream on his I'm a Donald then oh my god
he's my bts look at him he has a little cream on the top of
his head i don't know why couldn't you be why weren't you
there in my in my battle okay guys i want to put tails in um
let's see i want to go to where's my team
whoa what's your story apathy okay that's your story wait is
there whoa oh my max love oh wait where's uh i wanna wait
i'm missing one cookie who am i missing i'm actually missing
one cookie Whoa, how could I be missing one cookie?
I want to change my Lodo.
I want to change my cookie Lodo.
Okay, let's see.
Build Kingdom Affairs.
Dashboard Shop.
It's Butterfly.
What does butter roll cookie look like?
I'm back.
Gotcha.
Where are you butter roll cookie?
Where are you?
Found, found, found, found, found, found, found, found,
found, found, found, found.
I can scroll to the bottom of the list.
Wait.
Oh!
The bottom's not the list tells me.
Sorry, there's so many cookies.
It's Cream Farrant!
The freaking curse.
My favorite is Cream Farrant.
Stupid Farrant.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, where's the, where's the, I'm
trying to, events.
Okay, there you go.
Wake up!
Wake up, you're my only cookie!
When, when, when did I get butter on my bed?
Wake up!
How do I get this?
You need to complete my collection!
I don't have it!
It's 1800!
Wake up!
You're supposed to babysit me!
You're literally the babysit ferret!
I used it all up.
I used up...
You're pretending.
You're pretending to be sleeping, aren't you?
I could tell you're pretending.
I know you're pretending.
I didn't have enough.
I didn't have enough, guys.
All right, let's see.
My cookie.
Okay, I wanted to change up my party.
Is it bonds?
Best birthday.
Oh, I have all the bond buffs, too.
That's crazy.
I need a fine tail I want to know Oh my god All these
designs are so pretty though My god there's a pumpkin cookie
That's not a cookie That is not a cookie We use Oh there's
tails Oh these are like the crossovers There's Sonic Level
31 Sonic There's all the promotions Oh That's so cute.
Where's like the...
Where's Goofy?
Wait, where is Goofy?
Rarity.
Oh!
Okay, wait.
By Rarity.
Who's the rarest?
Right here.
I can't believe I didn't get...
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I didn't...
I couldn't wake her up.
I'm so sad.
It's okay, I have Tails.
The strongest Tails out there.
You know what?
Tails is so strong that uh... Oh, it's like a cosmetic.
Oh, Tails is so strong that like... He can solo everything.
Oh no, I have no more star jellies.
I used up all of it.
I...
Oh, because I didn't read.
I never read.
Okay, I wanna Kingdom Arena.
what's this oh season one arena seasons okay i'm gonna redo
my team i want to redo my team uh
attackers all right where are you uh where are you tails
you're going in there just you though
clear i calculate a disaster You got this, Tails.
What's the worst that can happen?
Oh, wait.
You got this, Tails.
What's...
You can solo these, guys.
What's the worst that can happen?
I don't know what you're talking about.
the, literally, what's the worst I could, I have like 10,
you know, that what's the, there's a level 2!
Literally, what's the worst that could happen?
Yes, I wish to continue.
Nobody beats Miles, Tails, Prower.
Yeah!
Go Ysafality.
What are you gonna do?
Kill me?
Oh my god, you guys are not believing Tails!
Let's No!
Absolute PM.
I'm just sending tales.
Am I finding real people?
Tales sleep.
Wait, are these real people?
I believe.
That's right.
Oh, yeah, I'm teaching these children a lesson.
I mean, this is a lesson.
That's right, children!
All I need is one gig.
Get out of here!
Should have gotcha more children.
Go gotcha more child.
And you too can be just as good as Tails.
Teach them the real world.
I don't need to add Sonic.
Mattel's, Mattel's Day Ruin.
Who are you?
Level 5, get out of here!
Should have been the son of the creative cookie run.
My dad works at cookie run.
Get out of here!
190 steps!
That's cute.
I did 19,000 damage.
You only got 99%.
I only got 1% of my HP.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah!
Rink up!
Alright, nice.
Alright, who else?
Oh, you got... You have some... Oh!
Okay.
No, not you.
Alright, anyway.
Get in here and fight me.
That's right, child.
You were the first person I saw today.
Get out.
What's wrong with the...
No, no, it's just a misclick, guys.
It was a misclick.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I won my next fight.
I hate you.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing, Eric?
Yeah, why are you...
You two do not do two.
You know damn well.
million a pop oh a hundred and seven you have a hundred and
seven thousand i wait actually i don't know this is a little
risky this is this is just a little risky no i don't think
tails will make it okay they haven't healed it okay you're
right you're right you're Maybe I'll just bully this guy.
Get out!
Taro!
Get out.
There you go.
Easy.
Another 1%.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Easiest fight on my life.
Oh.
Tear.
bronze one where these where did these guys you know what I
can I can oh 13 oh you spent so much money on these two
characters clearly not enough go back and spend more money
go back and spend more money that's right oh what happened
to your Oh, that's cute.
Oh, wait, I can't move.
Wait a minute.
That's cute.
I'm going to roll in in eight seconds and destroy your
healer.
I don't need heals in one second.
Oh, what happened to your healer, little guy?
That's right.
Get out of my game.
Get out.
Yeah, that's like 80 buffs.
It's so over.
It's okay.
I got rid of their support.
That's all that matters My ranking oh, wait Put these babies
in here
There we go.
We don't need Sonic all we need is our really strong tails
That is overkill on that support.
How did you get in my Elo?
The dokey train does not stop.
Rink up.
Silver three.
Oh, the default den.
Oh, you have default den.
Should have gotchaed more.
You should have gotchaed more.
Get out.
Default den.
All right.
I'm not smurfing.
This is literally my first time playing
This is my first time playing this game.
I'm just that good.
I'm literally just, I'm that guy.
Oh yeah, but Tiger?
That's right.
You had a tiger.
Why did I do?
200k team.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm already in silver, too.
I don't know what you're talking.
What the heck?
2 million.
Bro, they have the whole god army.
Who put this guy in here?
2 million.
This is silver, too.
What are you doing here?
It's silver, too.
Oh my god, this is like a whole baby.
Look at how tiny they are.
Alright, this is my last battle card.
And then I get kicked out.
Fight that whip.
He's here for you.
There we go.
Back to the babies.
Yay!
Alright, I used up all my cards.
Alright, guys.
I can't fight any more of the children anymore, guys.
Wait, unless...
Unless...
Pay to fight more children!
Let's go!
JK, I have the money to fight more.
That's right.
goodbye nice go tails go I don't know if I can like but do I
when does the curse stop the ride never ends the ride never
ends what's the lowest oh the gnome we can't fast forward we
don't even get to see them fight fast forward yeah I think
yeah I think it's we know what's gonna happen on this one
too you don't even deserve me watching it because we know
what's gonna happen goodbye yeah how did you default dead
with the one guy with the one guy you know what no let's
Let's watch you.
Let's teach.
You know what?
I feel a little generous here.
Where's Tuxedo, man?
Where are you?
What color is Tuxedo man?
The bat.
Oh, wait.
It's a costume, right?
That's a bait.
Okay.
I need to remove you.
All right.
I don't want Is does he is a costume right guys Speedman's
top 500 goals Right here Alright You know what Let's go
There's no way I gotta put on the costume I'll be right back
I'm not done with you I'll be right back
Where are you no okay wait there we go there we go nice
there we go there no no all right child i'm coming back in
That's right, child.
I'm coming back in.
That's right.
Oh, that's cute.
618 versus 22,000.
Missed me.
Got the mirror match of the ages.
Who will win?
Yay!
I'm going to...
Two!
Yippee!
I'm close to...
Oh my god, with the two million!
Where are these...
Where's the children?
There we go.
There's the children.
Alright, get back in here.
I'm done playing with you.
I'm done playing with you, gal.
Alright, we all know what's gonna happen.
There's no way.
Put her hand in the nuclear bomb.
Nice!
Alright, I just want to make sure I just want weed out the
children out of here so that everybody else will what?
No How How do I What happened?
What?
What happened?
How did it?
How did they stop me?
Is it because they all?
That's how they stopped me They they fought back The
children fought back No No, no, how did they stop tails?
No No 70 E-boss.
Because their power level says 57,000!
Of course I would fight him!
My win streak.
They... This is not fair.
I can't even... I can't even rematch them.
This is not fair.
I can't... I can't even... What is your name?
I will remember you.
All right, well, that was fun.
That was really fun.
I had a great time, honestly.
That's fun trying out Cookie Run for the very first time.
You know what?
No, we don't end on the loss.
You're right, guys.
We don't end on the loss.
Who's the refreshing?
All right, we don't end on a loss.
You're right.
We don't.
You're absolutely right.
Let me go.
Oh, no.
You're right, everybody.
No.
This is how we are ending.
Hey.
Hello.
We did it.
Yay.
Alright, and that's how...
And that's how we end the stream.
That's how...
not overkill if the children made it.
My dad works at Cookie Run.
But yes, that was the new update.
I hope you guys had a fun time.
I had a great time trying out for the first time.
Again, huge shout out to Cookie Run for the sponsor.
If you guys want to support this stream and support the game
as well, Feel free to check the link out in the description
And the pinned message on download and install the game It
really does help a lot, guys It was really, really fun And I
definitely enjoyed it a lot So thank you again Thank you
guys, I hope you guys had a fun time watching I understand
why this game is incredibly popular Especially the designs
The designs are The designs are really, really pretty i have
to admit like uh i really liked looking at like all the
character designs of the cookies and obviously like so much
love being put into this game so yes thank you again um as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys Ooh!